out of sight in the white house for the
moment but still
using his power as president donald
trump settling scores
sacking his defense secretary mark esper
finding out he'd been
terminated by tweet esper dubbed jesper
by the president
finally fell foul of the oval office in
the summer as racial justice protests
swept american cities
the president considered putting troops
on the street esper
insisted that wasn't going to happen the
election is still on donald trump's mind
sending out a series of tweets about
states he claims are in dispute
in the senate the republican leader said
the president was right
not to concede right now president trump
is 100 within his rights to look into
allegations of irregularities
and weigh his legal options but his
democratic counterpart admitted
he was worried where the president was
taking the country
baseless claims by the president and his
supporters
that there's been widespread voter fraud
and that the election
was somehow rigged or stolen from
president trump
that kind of rhetoric is extremely
dangerous republicans say
they're just at the start of the legal
battle this election
is not over and are pulling together
evidence
to put before the courts we do have a
whistleblower which i discussed
earlier this week who was in detroit as
an election worker
not as a republican poll watcher who
under affidavit
says that they were told to back date
ballots that
their supervisor came and they were
there on november 4th
ballots that came in with no date they
were told by the supervisor
back date the ballots to november 2nd or
november 3rd so they will count so that
has been submitted
to the eastern uh to the u.s attorney in
the eastern district of michigan
attorney general william barr has told
prosecutors to investigate
any substantial allegations of fraud
before the results are verified
it's been seen by critics as a political
move to give more credibility
to unfounded allegations made by the
president
joe biden is in no doubt though he's won
and he's already getting ready for day
one
as america hit 10 million covert cases
he announced his coronavirus task force
which will go to work straight away i
will
spare no effort to turn this pandemic
around
once we're sworn in on january 20th to
get our kids back to school safely
our business is growing and our economy
running at full speed again
and to get an approved vaccine
manufactured and distributed as quickly
as possible
to as many america as to as many
americans as possible
free of charge we'll follow the science
two more people who are at the
president's election night event have
tested positive for covet
cabinet secretary ben carson and david
bosse
who is leading the legal efforts in the
contested states
as america faces a spike in cases vice
president mike pence who leads the
administration's coronavirus task force
is heading to florida for five days on
vacation
alan fisher al jazeera washington
chris haynes is an associate professor
of political science and legal studies
at the university of new haven he joins
us live on skype
from milford connecticut chris it's
actually in your title
political politics and legal they're the
two crucial things that are going
on here right now what is the first
priority
uh for the trump campaign is it
controlling the narrative or is it
getting
this uh legal process underway
you know it's really not it's really not
clear what the trump
trump administration's strategy is um
obviously they're trying to control the
narrative
but the narrative itself is something
that has really gotten out of control
for them joe biden by conducting these
uh shadow or separate news conferences
um he is the president-elect in the eyes
of most of the media
and the and the united states being
congratulated by
president george w bush and other
republicans the narrative has already
spun out of control so his
i guess right now it's legal strategy
but a legal strategy that is founded on
a lot of unsubstantiated claims of voter
irregularities and voter fraud
it doesn't look like he has anywhere to
turn but chris this is also about the
transition as well which hasn't taken
place
that's a traditional thing that takes
place every time there's a change
in government but it's stalled right now
but does
that mean that there is a potential
power vacuum or even
a power vacuum already
yeah i mean what it really suggests is
that the president
is not ready to concede that people that
he
is appointed and republicans are not
willing to cross him
you've already seen what happens when
you do that and you know today he just
fired the defense secretary by tweet
and so what it really suggests is that
we need to wait
in a way for president trump to come to
the realization that
he's not going to win this election and
he does need a peaceful
transfer of power and for those under
him to receive
that message but he's got a long legal
battle ahead of him it has to go
from court to court to court and he
keeps president trump
keeps talking about the supreme court so
he needs to
lose several battles before he gets to
the supreme court
and he's gambling everything on that
isn't he
you know he is and uh uh i mean
the reality is i'm not sure if it'll
ever become a reality that'll ever even
get to the supreme court
um you really need substantial cases of
election fraud
and not only that you need cases where
that election fraud could actually be
decisive and overturn uh the decision
of multiple states you know we had
uh an issue we had a situation in the
year 2000 when
george w bush and al gore were
contesting florida
but in that case uh they were it was
completely different it was a single
state
where there were a lot of voting
irregularities and and voter issues with
the ballots
in this election we have multiple states
that trump would need to
overturn and it's just not clear if
there are any cases that are going to be
substantial or decisive
uh to warrant a court review chris
haynes
thank you very much joining us from
milford connecticut
absolutely thank you